[Musique]
l'histoire de françois mitterrand en
bourgogne commence à cluny en saône et
loire
au début des années 40 celui qui se fait
alors appeler françois morland à nîmes
dans la résistance un réseau de
libération de prisonniers de guerre
c'est dans le maquis de cluny qu'il
rencontre daniel à peine sortis de
l'adolescence est déjà très impliqués
dans la résistance
françois mitterrand découvrira alors la
maison familiale de danielle gouze la
roma d'acronymes des trois prénoms des
enfants 12
roger madeleine et daniel une maison
déjà chargé d'histoire où les parents de
daniel abritèrent deux grandes figures
de la résistance
henri freiner et berty albrecht le 28
octobre 1944 françois mitterrand épouse
danielle la veille de ses 20 ans le
couple séjournera souvent à cluny et
dans cette maison chargée d'histoire une
histoire que françois mitterrand devenu
président aura à coeur de venir
commémorer françois mitterrand était cet
après midi à cluny près de mâcon un
voyage symbolique qu au cours duquel le
chef de l'état voulait rendre hommage
aux résistants français autour du
président de la république aujourd'hui à
cluny
plusieurs dizaines de résistants dont
les amis de l'époque de monsieur
mitterrand
messieurs bettencourt et de chartres par
exemple venu pour célébrer le souvenir
d'une rafle à cluny
il y à 40 ans de cela soixante-dix
personnes déportées habib kane valent
aux chevilles et dachau dont 42 ne
reviendrai jamais souvenir également
d'une autre résistante de cluny berty
albrecht assassinés par les nazis
tout comme l'ancien maire de la ville
jacques guéritaine cérémonie qui ont été
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état évoqué
l'effort de l'époque pour regagner la
liberté de la patrie et la nécessité
d'un effort différents mais
indispensable pour aujourd'hui
ces visites à cluny dans la famille de
daniel transformeront aussi parfois la
roma dahan lieu de revendication en 1983
les anciens salariés au chômage de moto
standard à mâcon vient ici offrir une
tondeuse au président ils seront
rejoints par des salariés de saint
gobain inquiet pour leur entreprise
durant son second septennat françois
mitterrand ne changera pas ses habitudes
et accordera toujours à cluny une
attention particulière quand il décide
par exemple pour 1989 d'un budget
conséquent pour la restauration du
patrimoine c'est tout naturellement à
cluny qu'il vient d'annoncer françois
mitterrand a donc indiqué ce matin à
cluny qu'il fallait développer les
dispositifs de protection des sites en
rappelant que dans le projet de budget
de la culture plus d'un milliard de
francs serai l'an prochain affectés aux
travaux de restauration cette brève
visite dans une province familière aura
une nouvelle fois permis au chef de
l'état de flâner entre l'art et
l'histoire sur les traces de lempire
tunisien en 1993 françois mitterrand va
même réservé une surprise aux élèves de
la prestigieuse ensam
pour nous c'était un week-end week-end
typique de à cluny on passe à cluny et 6
transforme tout d'un coup un week-end
exceptionnel
donc on est encore sous le choc le
président est venu en visite non
officielle à l'abbaye avec l'un de ses
amis c'est michael gorbatchev qui
l'accompagnent en ce mois de mai 1993
les deux hommes iront ensuite planté un
chêne dans les jardins du château de
cormatin jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
françois mitterrand reviendra
régulièrement à cluny et notamment à la
pentecôte un jour de 1946 son beau frère
roger goodell lui fait découvrir à
quelques kilomètres de là la roche de
solutré sous le charme françois
mitterrand se promet d'y revenir chaque
année
il le fera jusqu'en 1995 il meurt le 8
janvier 1996 à l'âge de 79 ans après la
polémique que soulève le souhait du
président de reposer au mont beuvray
dans la nièvre il sera finalement inhumé
à jarnac en charente son lieu de
naissance
en 2011 la mort de danielle mitterrand
ramène l'histoire du couple à cluny
c'est là dans le caveau familial
clunisiens que repose aujourd'hui
l'ancienne première dame de france